[music]
[applause]
all the same Leodais was loaded in
Feodosia in the Russian-occupied
Ukrainian Crimea, the cargo
comes from the Russian-occupied
territories of Zaporizhzhia and Kherson Oblast with the approval of the embassy
[music]
[music] a
brand new car, a new Lada was bought  on
what is popularly called grave, the father
says that Aleksey dreamed precisely about the
White attack, he goes to the cemetery for the first time
[music]
words of support for the Ukrainians were expressed by
actresses Angelina Jolie, Jennifer
Aniston, Penelope Cruz, Sarah Jessica
Parker, Jessica Chastain, Oscar-winning
actor Robert De Niro, Elijah Wood, and G
Laurie who speaks and who acts Oscar winner
Spaniard Javier Bardem went to an
anti-Russian protest on the first day of the
war Ana Reynolds and Blake Lovely
opened a fundraiser for Ukrainian
refugees, they promise to double any
donation made
[music]
[applause]